welcome to another edition of the
Sinquefield cup it's been a couple of
months and since the tournament's in
Paris and live and tell us a little bit
about what you've been doing main thing
as I played a tournament Bilbao where
were I be at Magnus Carlsen had a pretty
decent result plus one
I played one tournament in Dortmund I've
been studying and I also played a
tournament in between in Spain hopefully
some chairs in the meantime nothing
overly proud that I'm going to report to
you now I honestly haven't been haven't
been doing much chess you know a lot of
holidays and family line they spend some
time at home with family I had some work
that I had to do some speeches had to
give and things like that celebrated my
birthday metal put a lot of friends and
had a pretty good time but now I'm ready
to focus on Chester three days before
the tournament psychos who are ready to
focus on Jax I'm up to second in two
words and I won my last two tournaments
back to back in Dortmund and built so I
don't know if they say in the US but in
France they say I never to without three